I mean obviously you've always had a
a strong inclination to combine there's
the music but you've always in in a way
that I I feel like uh very similar to
David Bowie you've always wanted it to
also be a great theatrical experience
you've wanted it to
I mean I remember the the giant suit and
stopped making sense and how arresting
that was what how how
um
what a great idea that was and so you
have
this
your physicality and the way you moved
and then the suit and how they're
fighting each other but also
complementing each other and it it
burned a hole in my brain at the time
and I think for a lot of people it did
but
um where did that sensibility come from
do you think were you always interested
in that in in making it Visual and
Theatrical
um
little by little I think at first
I mean I again growing up seeing like
David Bowie shows and some other kinds
of things I realized oh that is
a thing that can can be done you can do
a kind of
theatrical show with where costumes or
whatever that's not completely out of
the question
and but I thought no but we don't know
what to do so
we started off trying to take it down to
ground zero and not do anything
just wear street clothes on stage and
not have any kind of look of course not
having a look ends up being a look yeah
there's no way you can't escape it uh so
after a while little by little started
incorporating
things like a little bit of movement
this and that more and more a little bit
of lighting at first we had no lighting
we would say to the we'd go into a club
and just say just turn them on when we
start and then turn them off when we're
done
really really an on off just someone
with an on off switch basically yes
sorry I know you want to be creative but
please
um we're not ready for that yet right
and yes and I
living here I started seeing kind of
downtown experimental theater and things
like that people doing different things
and I saw
uh
various kinds of performances and
whatever and I thought
oh oh this all different ways of doing
this it doesn't have I don't have to be
like the various rock stars that I that
I know about that I might love but
there's other ways of doing things I
didn't necessarily copy those other
people but it kind of opened up a world
of uh
yeah
think outside the box think of what you
can do and
yeah I was trying to we'd finished a
tour
uh I was in Japan talking to a friend
over there
and I said
I'm not sure what to do on on stage for
our next tour and this guy said well
being kind of facetious saying well you
know in the theater everything has to be
bigger
and I'm thinking about what I'm wearing
at that moment I was thinking what I'm
gonna wear so he drew on a napkin
a really really big suit
now being in Japan I was also thinking
of the kind of traditional theater there
like this uh genre of theater called no
they wear these are very wide shoulder
I've seen them outfits yes and they look
kind of flat when they turn to the side
it's like a big rectangle in front with
a head in the middle and the shoulders
are very obviously very Square yeah very
square and I thought
do that not have it look Asian but have
it look like
a kind of business person's suit
I don't know what that means but I
thought that could be nice
it's it feels like it means something
did you feel that the glasses also were
part of the aesthetic you know what I
mean or was it just I need to see no no
I didn't wear glasses then yeah and
you did in some videos yeah I did in
some videos but just for the look they
didn't have any glass in them uh I don't
think yeah it was just for the look that
I thought this person this character so
but I mean then you come from that you
start there but then as the you need to
as you evolve
and start playing with things you start
adding more and more but it starts very
stripped down
yes I didn't know what to do so thought
let's eliminate everything no guitar
solos maybe they're just a hint of a
guitar solo uh weightless we're gonna
wear our street clothes the lights are
just going to come on at the beginning
and go off at the end right all those
kinds of things uh no no choreography
all the sort of take away everything and
see what's left we kind of did that
musically too it was kind of let's
remove all the extraneous musical
elements so we only play what's
absolutely necessary
and then you can start to add other
things can creep back in when the band
breaks up
I think the last time you played
together was at a Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame induction yeah yeah how did it feel
when you guys were up there together
it was fun but it was tense yeah uh
I remember there were some musical
mistakes
that drove me around the bend yeah so
thought oh geez really now yeah yeah
here yeah there's the pluses and minus
of being in a band yeah and I have
always really admired the decision not
to
reform the band because I've always
thought
um
you know when something happens and it's
pure and then it's done there's a real
Beauty to stepping away from it is that
how you have felt
I love collaborating with people but
being with a band is yeah I have to say
it's it's really wonderful you're like a
family
you're like a little team a little army
all those kinds of things but then after
a while it gets all the kind of
for all the kind of negative stuff in a
family
is there as well as the positive stuff
right who took my toothbrush yeah yeah
do you have to chew like that yeah
I think it was Lauren Michael said to me
once he was describing I don't know if
it was Rowan and Martin or some famous
comedy team but he said
when when you're down and out and you're
working your way up in the clubs you
look at your part and you think thank
God he's up here in on stage with me at
this dive
but then when you hit it the huge big
time you look over at that guy and you
go what the hell is he doing here
it's not it's just human nature but also
things run their course yeah did you
ever work with a team like that no I
mean I worked I was I've always been
very collaborative uh in in my I started
out as a writer and I was a comedy
writer for a long time and that was very
collaborative
and uh and I
enjoyed that but
um I also started to when I started
performing I I found that oh I'm kind of
a control freak and uh it's easier when
not everything is a collaboration so
it's the yin yang it's
uh you want it to be the way you have it
in your head you want to hear it the way
you hear it in your head whether it's
comedy or music
um and it's a it's a struggle it's a
struggle to the collaborations are great
but then there's those moments when you
think can I can I just tell everybody
exactly what to do and then of course
your Mussolini yes who did not make it
in comedy by the way
uh I remember being like that at various
points being a control freak and say it
has to be this way it has to be this way
I'm gonna do it again we're gonna do it
again
um years go by and I realized you know
you
whatever uh whatever the phrase is you
catch more flies you get more something
with sugar or whatever it might be flies
go into sugar and die whereas honey can
cover sugar no so I'm not making this
any better but but I know what you're
saying it's supposed to be like catch
more flies with honey than vinegar
something like that so I knew that now
I'm a control freak we've got to get
this right yes so there's a fly okay I'm
sorry
completely broke down over this got into
a fight and then you left it was over
the same I'm gonna go look this up yeah
exactly I'm going to the New York Public
Library I want to choose your phone I
want to go to the library
um I don't trust the Internet
it's stealing my soul uh this is just
apropos of nothing but just because you
mentioned that are you kind of a lot are
you comfortable with technology are you
comfortable with internet uh phone or I
use it I mean I use the internet I uh
you don't have a mobile phone of course
but uh I'm not on social media right I'm
kind of suspicious of yeah what what
that does to people
um there's other things that I'm
kind of suspicious about uh
that whoops that the big tech companies
know so much about us and therefore are
kind of manipulating Us in various kinds
of ways
uh
it sounds I mean when the way I say it
it sounds like science fiction but it's
more like manipulating you to stay on
their platform and buy stuff that yeah
in subtle ways yeah
um do you ever use a typewriter yes I
have but I don't use it anymore I I know
you we all did use a typewriter I still
use a typewriter because I love the look
of them the same way I love the look of
a guitar I also love the look of uh
certain kinds of typewriters and I love
having them around and there is a little
niche cult out there of people like me
that still type people letters and put
them in the mail I'm sure people love
getting online they love getting a typed
letter
um even if it's quite abusive
I've written the creepiest most abusive
letters people like you type this this
is incredible I don't know you seem like
you would maybe fall into that pocket of
sometimes you know you want to ride a
bike you want to keep it simple yeah to
some extent to some extent I feel like
yeah enjoy your life and you don't have
to
you have to obsess over all this stuff